this report was meant to help the met
move forward but instead it's reignited
a row about the resignation of its
former chief
by stating she faced pressure from the
mayor to resign
over 116 pages the former chief
inspector of constabulary sir thomas
windsor reached this conclusion
due process was not followed by the
mayor of london in the mayor's office
for policing and crime so when she stood
aside the report says she was in effect
constructively dismissed by him and she
felt intimidated in the process
it's led to a war of words breaking out
between the two
chris the dick says the report found
sadiq khan's behavior to be oppressive
unreasonable entirely unacceptable and
unfair
but sadiq khan has battled back calling
the review clearly biased and doubling
down on his view that on cressida dick's
watch trust and the police fell to
record lows following a litany of
terrible scandals no sarah i don't know
those include the murder of sir everard
by serving police officer wayne cousins
findings of institutional corruption and
its handling of the murder of daniel
morgan and racism misogyny and
homophobia exposed at charing cross
police station it was just one disaster
after another scandals this former chief
superintendent feels needed to be
addressed with action
it's almost like the dead cat principle
you know let's look at the real issues
let's not look at get behind the new
commissioner sir mark rowley let's try
and move forward but the conservative
leader at city hall says this is also
about how the mayor conducts himself in
office sadiq khan showed a certain
amount of uh support for cressida dick
by giving her an extra two years
extension
uh to her contract and then within a
couple of months when things weren't
going well on historical issues he threw
under a bus saying he'd put her under
notice that is unacceptable
this report has shed new light on
disagreements between the mayor and his
former commissioner
it's also a reminder of the present
issues and public scrutiny facing a
force that has been placed in special
measures for the first time in its
history
that decision taken by her majesty's
inspector of constabulary followed an
inspection that found a number of
failings
there are also two inquiries on the way
looking at the culture in the met
change is imminent at the top of the met
with new commissioner sir mark rowley
due to start this month in a deeply
political role it's the legacy of his
predecessors that could be his biggest
challenge shinki marike sky news new
scotland yard